if you needed another indicator of where
this cost of living crisis is taking us
it's here in the Players Lounge at
greenside Cricket Club 20 degrees
and that'll mean you've got a warm space
warm space just in the borough of
gateshead there are 65 venues opening
their doors for people
eat somewhere warmer than their own
homes this winter
it's Victorian isn't it it's a bit odd
it's just something I've never thought
of or dispute like
societally it's just a huge thing like
that there's people not even just people
you know on Universal Credit going to
struggle it's a it's it is universal
everybody's going to struggle it's just
tedious really and I'm just so pleased
that we can do this People's Energy
bills are just one part of the puzzle
the clubhouse here already doubles as a
weekly Food Market three pounds buys you
The Pick of what's on offer
you don't really care when you're seven
months old but Lena's mum is feeling it
I think the fact that people are gonna
have to come here to sit to be warm I
mean come on it's like it's getting a
bit ridiculous
Jesse's hoping she won't need to come
here for heat but they're expecting that
many others will
and this is happening all over the UK
and quite simply it's never been needed
before and the problem that all of these
venues have got is that quite often when
people leave them they'll still be going
back to cold homes
the UK government has intervened and
limited the rises in household energy
bills along with various discount
schemes but for so many families it
still isn't enough when the price of
everything else is soaring
so we predict that by January as many as
many as two and three households could
be really struggling with essential
household expenses now that's a terrible
number it's I think it equates to
something like 24 million households as
a network we're expecting a tsunami of
demand to come through our door they
will do what they can but people here
don't want warm spaces they want warm
homes they want to live not just to
survive inside a Cricket Club
Tom Parmenter Sky News gateshead